[Music]
we are going to make boy band history
tonight bro you're making baby Branch
nervous I feel like I'm going to barf
and pass out and pee your pants all at
once how' you know give it up for
[Applause]
[Music]
R you stop my exquisitely chiseled rock
hard abs and I quit franch we're we're
out of sink we've gone from Boys to Men
and now there's only one direction for
us to go the back streets bye see you
later gr what oh hey are you all right
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my
face baby Branch I'm John Dory Branch's
brother what ow former brother drama
call me
dinkle it's hard to say say I'm sorry a
brother is a friend who can never leave
you it's the strongest bond in the world
I would kill to have a sibling to sing
with check out your old outfits puffy
jacket pcas shell necklaces denim tuxedo
did you have frosted tips look at you
you are so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic bran our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit who was a Doty McMahon's face the
better question is are you a
narc who comes
there we're here looking for our
[Music]
brother oh my gosh
hello my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
CH did you just braid my hair you're
welcome it looks so good I love it is
your dad King Peppe uh yeah poppy I'm
your sister my what wa hey man am I the
only one without a long lost sibling
this is your second chance with your
brothers
Branch b b maybe a smaller diaper if
this diaper was any smaller I could
taste it I know you think it's risky and
maybe it is but it'll be worth it
family's always worth it I ever I can't
believe this is really
[Music]
happening we still got it looks like
your bandaid aren't behind you
just let me take you to a better
place I'm going to make
kiss Wing
deployment
Elin here we
[Music]
go this isn't about
migration it's about about
Adventure is that a little scary sure
you need a
hug can you let go now you feel better
no then it hasn't kicked in
yet there's a whole world we've been
missing out
on things we didn't even know
existed
what is that dange what's
dange it's you with laange on
top 3 2 1 Asha I'm here I'm here just
one second let me catch my breath Once
Upon a Time the Rosas the most Magical
Kingdom founded by a king with the power
to grant wishes you are their handsomest
most beloved King you're right I am a
handsome king I'm so nervous I think I'm
going to explode my best friend the
king's Apprentice my mouth trooping I
feel like it's
trooping Asha come with me the wishes of
roses wow people give their wishes to me
and I grant the wishes I am sure are
good ver Rosas some of these will never
be granted not some most they deserve
more than I decide what everyone
deserves
[Music]
so I look up at the stars to guide me I
wish and
throw oh you spoil us with your magic I
didn't do it
what last night I made a wish on a star
uh on a star
[Music]
answered
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low I believe I have
just been threatened who would dare
threaten
you I have no response to that so I that
there is a traiter amongst us find
Asha every it's a dead end with unsanded
mahogany oh good Vine Valentino my butt
found
it
[Music]
I started this I have to finish
it so
I wish what are you hiding nothing is to
be Liv and nobody what is going on in
there okay ladies your wings can't fly
but your voice is
can when our world is
threatened one team is ready to launch
did he say launch uh no I said launch
the Manor's heading straight for
us get down
wo it's giving off some kind of
energy I didn't do
it no way this September I think we' got
superpowers and that's why I wear a
heart hat got the power I feel the need
for super speed I'm a wrecking ball
surf look at your
paws great now the clumsy puup shoots
Fireballs out of his paws a new breed of
Heroes superpowers are real hits the big
screen we're going to need a new name
for ourselves how about the PAW Patrol
but more but just a little bit extra yes
how about the mighty
pup those to be my superpowers coming in
hard I'm going to take them one by
one oh my goodness I could
talk I have so much to say give me that
Showtime well well well Humdinger he
looks different than I
remember all right puppy play time's
over can you go up against one of us you
go up against all of us let's
go now that we're super I'm never going
to get to sleep well you're probably
more tired than
he you've got to be kidding
me
[Music]
for centuries we have called out to the
universe looking for
answers in
2024 the
universe
calls
back bring us your
[Music]
[Applause]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay bye I love you I love you
I you love
you this is
new no no no no no no thank
you
WAOW please State the name of your home
world uh Earth welcome leader of uh
Earth we are the United advanc species
of the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of all
Earth sorry for the mix up commence
memory WIP no
wait I am the leader of Earth why is
your voice different I I've always
talked like this since I was a kid which
I'm obviously not anymore but yes I run
the planet the trial of Earth can
proceed uh-oh until then as you say on
Earth okay bye I love you okay okay I
love you I love you I love
you you're the talk of the communiverse
if Mom could see me now I know what you
mean I ate my mother at Birth but in
moments of great success I regret it
that's a thing for your species no just
a me thing everyone was
[Music]
shocked
welcome to Jurassic
Park he did it he actually did
it you have a
T-Rex
you know the tale everything that
happened on the island the
big the the
[Music]
beasts you never heard about it well
then slip into something comfortable and
settle your Caboose into that seat
because you are about to go on an
adventure of prehistoric
proportions I am covered in Dino
snot
hold on to your butts my
friends oh you're going to stick your
hands in there yeah I brought gloves
well no no I'm just
kidding where is he
going when you got to go I guess you got
to
[Music]
go is that it they all gone oh come on
Minnie this is it let's get the gang y
picture time guys okay come on everybody
here we
go
water 100 Years of
stories make a
pink make it boo 100 Years of
magic oh help and B do you think all the
villains will show up not
all celebrate 100 Years of Disney with
Disney's new original short film Once
Upon a studio World broadcast Premiere
October 15th only on ABC be
careful welcome to canville chase our
new
home in the past every owner of this
house has been forced to
flee by the ghost of Simon to
canterville I don't think you're that
scary at all oh ghost or no ghost this
family are here to
stay I hate it here okay good to
look Henry Fitz Humphrey we used to own
the place until the ghost drove us out
really I need your help to scare my
parents out of
[Music]
here a goblin do you mind sir this is my
house no sir this is my
[Applause]
housea I'm a ghost who cannot haunt
Hello Ghost wait oh
I failed you we can't just give up
delightful of you to call on us Reverend
Bo this is not
funny so how many ghosts have you
actually caught technically this will be
my first this
way that's a
[Music]
covered I want to see the world have
adventur
[Music]
Henry slw down you kill us you're a goat
you're already dead oh
yes
[Music]
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for anpa
Luma Ana what now in fact in Lumpa land
I am regarded as something of a Whopper
they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie want you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed a
taper inventor may I present Willy
Walker's wild and wonderful wishy-washy
WKA Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
ooh he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head H know the B on what is
with me
today you should stand up to those
bullies give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course run away every good thing in this
world started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world I'm not in premium of me good
night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
stick
speee
spee
[Music]
you should sh
that
[Music]
my name's mes Morales I'm
Spider-Man he's going to be here any
give me your money so are you like a cow
or a Dalmatian ah
Spider-Man there's bubbles now hold
on I don't think I want this costume
anymore how's this going miles's grades
are pretty good A in AP Physics that's
my little man and a B in Spanish what
okay miles are you
TR miles want to get out of here come to
spider Society I'm Spider-Man oh no way
all of us
are meet Miguel O'Hara there's moments
in our stories that are the same for all
of us some good did you bring our baby
to another fight he asked me not to so I
didn't I'm bad you have a choice between
saving one person and saving every world
I can do both all station stop
Spider-Man you
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah I'm going to do my
own thing could this day get any
weirder I guess it can there's nowhere
to
run my bad everybody there was somewhere
to run June 2 this film is not yet
rated I'm the greatest hunter in the
land there's no Beast I can't Vanquish
no prey I can't slay tried to is sacred
to my kingdom I get your big fork and I
become ruler of land and oceans with
magic mirror as my loyal assistant I
serve no one but myself we'll talk who
would dare challenge
[Music]
me Daddy who did this to you the name's
Gaston release my father at once Gaston
Must Be Stopped we're ready count me in
and I have an axe
let's go okay ladies let's storm this
Castle fruit basket don't eat that come
on not without us you don't 1 2 3
4 where are we Ariel it's a treasure
map Keep Your Hands to
[Music]
Yourself Snow
White no my indestructible armor that
girl is seven gems short of a diamond
mine say goodbye
princesses we'll never give
up let's
go meet the residents of element
City air usually has their head in the
clouds oh my new jacket Earth can be a
little
seedy nothing weird going on here uh
just a little
pruning water is always getting into
[Music]
something help and fire as ordered we
run a little
[Music]
hot this shop is three name of our
family someday it'll all be yours but we
all live by one simple rule NM cannnot
mix what the pipe squished me all out of
shape
dang that's better
oh so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix hey plus my dad
would boil you alive why does anyone get
to tell you what you can do in your life
come
on why do they even have these eh who
knows watch
this
WOW Ember I see a change in
you water ha guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere Mar
follow
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes but I never once asked what I
wanted to
do try F dad those are too hot I love
hot
[Music]
[Applause]
food you see he likes
it
the world's most famous explorer is
back like you've never wow seen her
before join Dora and all her friends I'm
Boo in the magical new short film you'll
never find me follow that fox Dora and
the Fantastical creatures super see it
with Paw Patrol the mighty movie only in
theaters September 29th we have a very
important mission for tonight we must
use
stealth and cunning to infiltrate the
human world and
retrieve
go go okay Batman dude what I'm just
trying to Hype you guys up let's go from
Seth Rogan comes a movie that crushes
for absolutely every
age amazing insane all right tell me
more
it's effortlessly cool and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this
year that seems very dangerous be danger
for breakfast actually I eat pizza with
bits of waffles on
it with the funniest cast ever assembled
surprise yes BR I
I enough oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do
this I'm awesome we're brothers we fight
together we're just getting
[Music]
started yeah she sounded like a leader I
do oh I do oh I sound like such a leader
and you're R it Ninja
Turtles remember don't let any human see
you
hey exclusively in movie theaters August
2nd get your tickets
[Music]
now the
Jer as you can see Metropolis has gone
positively Gotham since the Justice
League disappeared it's out of Trace but
with they missing who do you call when
your Heroes need Heroes
Krypto he can fly and he's got his
vision now we can find out what happened
to the Justice League faster than a
speeding bullet more powerful than a
locomotive just like
Superman oh no we're sealed in all you
have to do is unmask this Phantom before
all these out of control villains
destroy the
world
giganta those konian
Exiles Solomon
Grundy rat's
right Krypto all right all right we have
to look for Clues what's the point
what's the point of any of this why am I
trapped in here with a bunch of annoying
kids Krypto oh yes super
duper thanks pal
super who's a good boy who's a good
boy now hold
in
huh this is super
lion his identity is a
secret no one knows who he really
is except for me because he's my dad
dad and this is me
hedvi how was your day at school hedvi
just super the job of super lion gets
passed down and I'm
next I am the new super
[Music]
lion is that a super lion it looks like
a super Chihuahua you're just no
superhero
HFI I have to find someone that I
believe
in oh
yes you need to be careful with that
suit because it enhances your best
qualities but also your worst can you
train me now when do we
[Music]
start but everyone's got something right
one thing that they're truly passionate
about gaming
woo we have found your
[Music]
superpower everything will
[Applause]
collapse no one will ever stop me fine
he's out of control your
own
superpower
Daddy just super I didn't know that you
had a motor motorcycle license well I
don't here we
[Applause]
go first my mother and now your father
they've both come back to us I have so
few memories Catching Fire is just a
king and Young Prince kind of thing but
I clearly remember he loved me does King
Derek no he knows nothing what don't I
know your father was a king accused of
trying to make a deal with pirates I
don't believe it someone knows the truth
about my father we have never falsely
accused anyone especially not your
double dealing
father as they go under cover to face
their que challenge yet finding
truth go home how could they know who we
are
[Music]
a merchant ship will pass in 2 days he's
working with pirates exactly what he
accused my father of it's important that
you tell us everything you know only
Captain firebeard can tell you more a
pirate ship is no place for a queen I'll
be a queen tomorrow but a pirate today
no recruit
Captain you brought me a girl pirate can
you cool and so the only thing I've ever
stitched was me own busted skull once or
twice you heard of King Max then and how
he disappeared had to whip up a little
diversion to get him out to
scene and that was the end of all
Max celebrate the thrilling conclusion
of the Timeless TS hearts
King
[Music]
maximilan hold you in my
heart it's almost like you're
here with me no
[Applause]
[Music]
far us one last time and witness
Unforgettable moments of Hope and
courage where love can last far longer
than Forever The Swan
[Music]
[Laughter]
Princess
[Music]
he